so what's the connection between diet
and sleep
so i do intermittent fasting sometimes
only one meal a day sometimes no meals a
day
is there a good science on the
interaction between
fasting and sleep
we have some data i would prefer more
but we have data both on
time restricted eating
and then
we have some data on
fasting to a degree
on time restricted eating
i think that it has some benefits
although the human replication studies
have actually not borne out quite the
same health benefit extent
that the animal studies have have been
some disappointing
studies one here close to where we are
right now at ucsf recently
so i think time-restricted eating can be
a good thing and there are many benefits
of time restricted eating is sleep one
of them no it doesn't seem to be
because there are probably at the time
that we're recording this three pretty
decent studies that i'm aware of
um two out of the three were in obese
individuals one out of the three were in
healthy weight individuals and what they
found was that time restricted eating in
all three of those studies didn't have
any advantageous benefit to sleep it
didn't necessarily harm sleep but it
didn't seem to improve it
when it comes to fasting though which is
a different
state
we don't have too many studies
experimental studies with long-term
fasting the best data that we have is
probably from religious practices and
probably the most data we have is during
ramadan where people will fast for 29 to
30 days from sunrise to sunset
and under those conditions there are
probably
there are probably five distinct changes
that we've seen
none of them seem to be particularly
good for sleep the first is that the
amount of melatonin that you release a
melatonin is a hormone it's often called
the hormone of darkness
or the vampire hormone not because it
makes you look longingly at people's
necklines but it's just because it comes
out at night yeah melatonin signals to
your brain that and your body that it's
dark it's nighttime and it's time to
sleep
those individuals when they were
undergoing that regiment of fasting
they
the amount of melatonin that was
released and when it was released the
amount of melatonin decreased
and when it was released came later that
was the first thing the second thing was
that
they ended up finding it harder to fall
asleep as quickly as they normally would
otherwise
the third thing was that the total
amount of sleep that they were getting
decreased
the fourth fascinating thing was that a
wake promoting chemical called erectin
increased and this is why a lot of
people will say when i'm fasting it
feels like i can stay awake for longer
and i can i'm more alert i'm more active
and i'll come back to from an
evolutionary perspective why we
understand that to be the case
and then the fourth factor is that
fasting didn't decrease the amount of
deep sleep that seemed to be unaffected
it did however decrease the amount of
rem sleep or dream sleep and we know
that rem sleep dreaming is essential for
emotional first aid mental health it's
critical for memory creativity it's also
critical for several hormone functions
it's when you know if you there's direct
correlations between testosterone you
know testosterone release peaks just
before you go into rem sleep and during
rem sleep too
so rem sleep is critical
but so those are the five changes that
we've seen none of them seem to be that
advantageous for sleep but the fourth
point that i mentioned which was orexin
which is this wake promoting chemical
and a good demonstration or a very sad
demonstration of its power is when it
becomes very deficient in the brain and
it leads to a condition called
narcolepsy
where you know you
you're just unpredictable with your
sleep and you um so
um
so erection when it's in high
concentrations keeps you awake when you
lose it it can you know it can put you
very much into a state of narcolepsy
where you're sleeping a lot of the time
in unpredictable sleep
why on earth when you are fasting
with the brain release awake promoting
chemical
and our answer is right now is the
following the one of the few times that
i mentioned before that we see animals
undergoing
insufficient sleep or
prolonged sleep deprivation is under
conditions of starvation
and
that is an extreme
evolutionary pressure and at that point
the brain will forego some it won't
forego all but it will forego some of
its sleep
and the reason is so that it can stay
awake for longer because the sign of
starvation is saying to the brain you
can't find food in your normal foraging
perimeter you need to stay awake for
longer so you can travel outside of your
perimeter for a fur further distance and
maybe you will find food and save the
organism so in other words when we fast
it's giving our brain this evolutionary
signal that you are under conditions of
starvation so the brain responds by
saying oh my goodness i need to release
the chemical that helps the organism
stay awake for longer which is erecting
so that they can forage for more food
now of course your brain from
revolutionary perspective doesn't know
about this thing called safeway
that you could easily go to and break
the fast
but that's how we understand fasting and
i think you know
my dear friend peter tier has um has
done a lot of work in this area too i
think fasting and david sinclair is
brilliant work goodness me what a an
individual to
the work is pretty clear there that you
know time restricted eating and fasting
have
wonderful health benefits time you know
fasting is
creates this thing called hermesis
just like exercise and
low level stress and sauna heat shock
and hormesis is a biological process i
think as david sinclair has once said in
simple layman's terms is what what
doesn't kill you makes you stronger
and
i think the
there is certainly good data that
fasting and time restricted eating has
many benefits is sleep one of them it
doesn't seem to be it doesn't seem to
enhance sleep but it's interesting to to
understand its effects on sleep i've um
like i've fasted
it's a study of nf2 i've once fasted 72
hours and another time 48 hours
and
i found that i got much less sleep and
it was very restful though
i hesitate to say this but this is how i
felt which is i needed less sleep
i wonder if my brain is deceiving me
because it feels like i'm getting
a whole extra amount of focus
for free
and
i wonder if there's long-term impacts of
that because if i fast 24 hours
get the same amount of calories one meal
a day
there's a little bit of discomfort like
just uh maybe your body gets a little
bit colder
maybe there's just i mean
hunger
but the amount of
focus is crazy yeah and so i wonder
it's like i'm a little suspicious of
that i feel like i'm getting something
for free it's i'm the same way with
sweetener
like uh splendor or something it's like
it's got to be really bad for you right
because why is this so tasty right and i
think yeah
as we said
for with biology
you know if there's
a gain there's yeah there's often a cost
too
so but
we at least understand the biological
basis of what you're describing it's not
that
you you actually don't need less sleep
it's that this chemical is present that
forces you more awake and so
subjectively you feel as though i don't
need as much sleep because i'm wide
awake
and those two things are quite different
it's not as though you your sleep need
has decreased it's that your brain has
hit the overdrive switch the overboost
switch to say we need to keep you awake
because food is in short supply
you